i don't know how that exactly came about
that you wrote with paul mccartney but
is it intimidating walking into the room
it is it is right yeah but he was great
about it he he
worked he just got down to work you know
and was sitting across a table we were
even a little closer than we are howard
yes and when you're doing that at first
he like what right do i have to tell him
or i feel funny bringing up an idea or i
don't even know the process he uses what
is his process well in the that i don't
know what you should come to each other
you go um
yeah exactly two guitars and a notebook
and a beginning or something
i had the beginning of uh the song
veronica he helped me finish that that
was about something serious you know it
was about my grandmother was was going
into alzheimer's it isn't the sort of
thing that you would typically write a
pop song about and i you could have
written a really sad ballad about it
yeah but i because i wanted still wanted
to hold on to the idea that there was
something in her mind that gave her some
comfort i wanted to make it a bright pop
song so it was kind of defiant and i
wanted it to be as bright and have as
many people hear it as i could there was
something
that's what i felt i should do with that
story and he helped me make it like that
elvis help me out here pretend i'm paul
mccartney okay
you're sitting there with him and you
have this tune in your head yeah and
you're sitting there with a guitar what
do you play for me is paul mccartney to
show me what's on your mind well i i
mean we realized the batter and perfume
[Music]
through pretty clothes that's scattered
around
the room
and it's so
so i played that and or something like
that and you go no it wants to be like
this or do that and put that bit in
after that and i wrote in the last verse
i wrote something about uh
she couldn't say goodbye he couldn't say
goodbye but
you know but you've got lousy taste and
he said you can't put you've got lousy
taste in a song you know he'd like i
said yeah well maybe she's writing this
letter to the guy and you know because
we're writing about it
when you're writing with somebody else
you can't write
the specific person that you know maybe
so much you've got to think about all
the people you've known and make up a
character is it possible in that session
to reject an idea of paul mccartney's
because he's paul mccartney yeah of
course you have to be able to i mean he
was you know you have to be able to have
disagreements i mean he would say
we were writing a song called you one or
two which was
alternate lines you know i've loved her
oh so long you know that's not what you
said the other night was every other
line was one was starry eyed and the
next one was cynical and we got halfway
through the playback and he turned down
the sound and said hold on a second
you're getting all the good lines here
because of course he'd been there before
you know obviously and i was trying very
hard not to kind of think i could be
like john lennon because i was just
stupid you know and uh
but then he kind of got at ease with the
fact that
he sounded good singing those
starry-eyed lines and i sounded good
singing the cynical lines and that was
what it was it was just making uh a
dialogue you know but in a way that it
is like john lennon because when john
does one song yeah when john wrote with
paul the legend goes that john was like
sort of like the edgy kind of you know
like maniac guy and then paul would sort
of yeah yeah but then you forget about
you don't lie thinking i can see
you can't cry cause you're laughing at
me i'm down right i mean you know who
sang that yeah probably better than i
just did
you know do you develop a personal
friendship with him he was very kind you
know it was like i i
him and his wife linda you know they
were very good right to us you know and
um don't you think in retrospect when
you were sitting and writing these
things shouldn't somebody have had a
video uh recording of this just for
posterity but not everything has to be
and sometimes when you put a video in
the room it inhibits everybody you know
you start playing to the camera i've
been in that situation a few times it
can it can ruin the intimacy i mean i i
the picture that i've got in the book is
just a picture of him and me in in a
lift you know in an elevator all right
taken by linda and it's just at his
office and she came through the door
just as we were going up for a meeting
about what we were going to do next yeah
and she just snapped us
and i'll take that picture because it's
just two guys on the way to work you
know yeah wow that must have been some
experience right that was great